nous connaissons votre site Web vos vidéos
votre blog nous ne savons pas pourquoi vous êtes si en
colère
ce qui se passe mr.  énigme nous avons un
mandat pour fouiller votre maison
sans armes avez-vous l'intention de faire
quelque chose alors êtes-vous né de Dieu non
c'est juste qui je suis les
gens n'aiment pas ça c'est dommage
tout le monde va faire prendre toute l'
équipe de hockey
quoi  es-tu prêt une histoire de vengeance
midi envie d'un bon moment commencer à
courtiser les 45s serait l'outil il sera
méthodique d'être sans émotion comme une histoire
beaucoup menaçant nos enfants qui
nous menacent tous
ta pièce appelle la mienne pour tout le mois il y a
deux semaines
appelez-moi : par un seul
qu'est-ce que vous dites nous mettons fin à tout ce qui se
passe je veux juste voir ce que je
pensais alors tu veux retourner en prison
je suis en prison [ __ ] tu ne le vois pas
la question est juste quoi  sorte de brûleur
ici